this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five as we talk about your
life that's why dr john's here and your
money
that's why i'm here and we'll probably
both interrupt each other as we go along
it's kind of what we do here
jamie is with us jamie is in scranton
pennsylvania hi jamie welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
well i wanted to ask you about a little
bit of a
shadow plan on buying my first home
um i have enough cash to
buy it cheap fixer-upper and pay cash
without a mortgage but
the problem i have is i need a garage
on site big enough to run a small
business out of
and i can't afford a property with a big
garage and a house
so i have to figure out if i'm better
off buying the house playing casual than
financing putting a building up or the
other way around
well i guess it's uh if it's the same
amount of money that you're going into
debt either way
it's just whichever property you want to
end up with right
i guess but the being self-employed it's
very difficult to get a mortgage
um i was kind of figuring that if i had
a property and help a deed to it it'd be
easier to get a loan for the building
no no no but it won't be the exact same
thing because in both cases
if you're struggling to get a mortgage
you're going to be going to a local bank
rather than a traditional mortgage
company
so of course the other option is to uh
you know buy a property to live in
and rent your garage somewhere else well
the problem the problem i have with that
is i'm sick of renting
um and i have a i have a young son that
i take care of every day he comes to
work with me now
and i'm reeling that realizing that in
this post-code world we're going to live
in that they're going to cancel school
for
any time somebody gets the sniffles so i
figure
i'm better off being prepared to have
him there every day with me
right yeah you know you understand what
i mean i want to be able to work and
and live in the same property so for
that
you're a single dad no no his mother
works full-time
and i take him to work with me so he
doesn't have to
go to daycare and stuff like that
so i'm a full-time dad part-time
business owner
i guess you would call me you sound like
somebody that's on the back end of a
really
frustrating trying exhausting year
and who is just fed up with the way that
the politics and the schools and all
that's being run especially up there in
scranton
and i would suggest not going into a
long-term
debt a 5 10 15 20 year
commitment financially over a current
just an exhaustion and a frustration
right now you know
i i agree i i don't know
when uh schools are going to normalize
but to project that they're never going
to normalize is
is not accurate right um
and i don't know exactly what's going to
occur
but is the entire public school system
in america going to be
uh apt to shut down with sniffles from
today forward no is it in some places
right now
yes is it not in some places right now
yes they're
i mean we're in middle tennessee and
it's pretty well open yeah and they're
not
freaking out they freak out more about
tornadoes than they do covered right now
and so um
uh more likely to shut down for that uh
so that that's to tell you that it has
normalized here
i guess if if you want to call the
phrase if normalized is a good word i'm
not sure it is a good word but anyway
uh to to dr john's point jamie i agree i
would not
uh build a life around this current
circumstance
i wouldn't build a a debt and a home
purchase around this current
circumstance
um and uh but it sounds to me like you
just don't want to rent and you're using
this as a justification too so
i'm buying a house and renting a garage
and if kids got to go to work with you a
couple times while you
rent the garage i just do that and um
especially while this is a part-time
business yeah
yeah um or you know buy a house and have
a small mortgage on that's got a garage
i don't care
and you can get that at your local
credit union or whatever
and if your wife has a full-time job and
makes an income
and you have a part-time business that
makes a profit that you pay taxes on
properly
you are bankable for a loan in that case
if you're trying to make zero money on
this garage
and show that on your taxes because
you're taking everything under the table
then uh you need to do your taxes
properly and not take it all under the
table and that'll help you get the loan
by the way but you're also supposed to
be paying taxes on that money
or you're really not making any money
you're not making a profit legitimately
in which case you're not bankable
so that's another thing and oh in which
case you wouldn't need to be renting a
garage either yeah because then you want
a garage for a cool hobby
uh where you're building something or
making something that you like but
you're not making money on it
exactly alex is with us in sioux falls
hey alex
welcome to the ramsay show hi thank you
what's up so i've
kind of dug myself a pretty big hole uh
relationship
wise and financially
um i'm about 55 000 in debt
not including my mortgage with
student loans credit cards and a home
equity loan
and i'm kind of just stuck i have i
think maybe a hundred dollars
to my name right now and i just yeah i
couldn't
i couldn't even afford my medication
that i needed for
depression last week and it's just
getting to the point where
i'm lost
are you working yeah
i make about 39 000 a year um
actually graduate college tomorrow so
congratulations that's man
what's your degree thank you uh
collision repair
so i'll work on cars i work for a family
business
your family yeah my family my grandpa
started this business and my dad owns it
now and
eventually i plan to take over it very
cool
so what's got you down relationally man
some some you sound like things are
heavy
i know you owe a lot of money but what
you got what's got you down on the other
side of that
um well i broke uh
i was engaged last
september and then things took a turn
for the worse and then
i started dating this other gal and
things were going really good and then
i got off my medication because i
couldn't afford it
and i didn't want to disappoint her
so i didn't tell her about it and
it really drove a stake into that
relationship
and yeah so things just ended this last
week and
so things have been really tough this
week
how much does your medication cost
i was about a hundred dollars for the
bottle
which lasts how long
uh about a month and a half
okay tell you what man we want to hang
with you a minute can you hang through
this commercial break so we can talk
some more
yeah all right we'll be right back with
you stick with me a minute
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john dolone ramsey personality
best-selling author
and host of the podcast that is
extremely popular
the dr john doloni show so you can join
him there be sure to jump in and do that
if you want to actually call him on that
you can do it at 844-693-3291 or you can
email him at ask
john ramseysolutions.com we're coming
back to alex and sue
falls just graduated with a degree in
collision repair he works for his family
business that does that
and i got off his meds and lost a
relationship uh the same week that he
graduated from college so a lot of highs
and a lot of lows a lot of sweet and
sour going on
meds cost a hundred and something a
hundred dollars for
uh a month and a half's worth and said
he can't afford him but he makes 39
000 a year so that's my first question
alex it sounds me like you can't afford
them and didn't buy them why
um i guess i don't i don't know like
i just don't know i'm not very good at
saving i
i see my friends go out and do all this
stuff all the time and i feel like i
should do it too and
yeah how old are you i'm 22.
okay how long have you been taking meds
for depression
um
since i was a sophomore in high school
so right around eight years
got it okay and you know one of the
cornerstone lies of
depression is that
this is always going to be this way
right that's what that's what that
blanket feels like that weight it's
always going to be like this
and one of the cornerstones of
depression is taking a small step of
healing from depression is another small
step
another small step getting people in
your life
and taking that other small step and
suddenly the sun starts to come out
right
yeah but it feels real dark and heavy
right now huh
yeah i'm sorry man
so something about you prioritizing alex
enough to buy the medication that you
need
to get the counseling and relational
help that you need
do you think alex is worth taking care
of
yeah i think i need to
open up more and be more
open about what i'm going through
because
i don't like people seeing me struggle
and let them know that i'm
struggling and i want to be strong and
just prove to people that i can do it on
my own
but obviously it's not working very well
you're not alone in that my friend
i'm having that same conversation right
now i'm still learning still growing
my friends that are my ages to learn is
still growing it's a powerful lesson you
can learn at your age
is to let people in let them know that
you're struggling and you want to want
them to
help meet your needs in some ways and
they all going to work on something
together
all right how uh i'm interested
in uh how successful you've been at
completing this degree
something made you able to
you know cast a long vision like that
and then go
do all of the steps to walk out the door
this week with that degree in your hand
what was it that allowed you to do that
because that sounds like something you
could attach to to me
yeah well i started out going to school
for business
and that was for my first two years out
of high school
and i was sitting in a business class
one morning and i asked
i just asked myself why am i doing this
i like to work with my hands i don't
want to sit behind a desk the rest of my
life and it's been
so how long was collision school how
long was collision school
two years so what enabled you to
complete a two-year
field of study successfully
touch down spike the ball do the
touchdown dance
what enables you to do that because i'd
like to attach that to you taking your
meds
i got a scholarship that no no no
no alex you know i'm talking about what
inside of you yeah you went to class
every day and crushed it
you did something you crushed this thing
man
i i don't know i like working with my
hands was somebody up in your grill
telling you you had to do it
my family the the or the family business
paid half of the money so i didn't want
to disappoint them by
dropping out of it and not completing
the
degree okay that's what i'm after so
what if we said i don't want to
uh what if we said i don't want to
disappoint them by not taking my meds
yeah because i'm going to call you on
something brother i'm going to love you
enough to call you can i do that
yeah you make thirty nine thousand
dollars a year you got a hundred dollars
you can't say i can't afford them that's
not true you can say i chose to buy
other stuff instead
that would be true but you can afford it
is that fair yeah okay
and when you say i don't want to let
them down whoever they happens to be
i want you to start putting yourself at
the top of that list
yeah i want you to love alex enough if
you live your life trying to make sure
other people happy that that's got an
expiration date on it brother it's not a
good way to go
you ma hey listen i've sat with kids in
med school i've sat with kids in law
school
who are two three degrees down the road
from you
and they did not have the courage you
had two years in the business school to
say what am i doing i want to do
something that i actually love and you
wouldn't
you wouldn't did it i like working with
my hands i'm good at it and you went and
did it
alex you realize what you did there you
said i'm important and i'm worth it
and so what i'm what we're suggesting is
we attach that same thing to your meds
because you may not need meds the rest
of your life but you apparently need
them today right
yeah and you know that the heartbreak
that you're experiencing right now is
not gonna last forever you know that
right
yeah okay you're a brave guy
the only person in the room that doesn't
realize how brave you are is you
and you're about to walk across the
stage you're going to walk into a job
that's going to have meaning attached to
it because it's got your family name on
the door
yeah all right so i you're talking to
two uh guys that have
enough uh sh have worn out enough shoe
leather over the years that
uh we know something about you that you
don't know
that when you're 32 all of this will be
in distance way in the distance in your
rear view mirror
if you continue to make progress along
these lines with your career
with your meds with your getting well
and uh
you can have a you know 10 years from
today this could be like the
you know the story that's in your past i
mean that's what it is
that's what it should be and that's what
that's what we actually see
in you that in this moment the no energy
in your voice
uh that you don't see in you and so all
we're saying is dude
like you prioritize going to class
prioritize those meds prioritize getting
well prioritize getting out in the
sunshine
prioritize being active uh prioritize
making sure you're seeing
your doc and that you're talking with
them and
prioritize that a decade from today alex
is uh um you know not facing these
things still
right that you've got a community you
got a gang around you that's going to
laugh with you and hold you accountable
and cry with you
and be heartbroken with you and then
take you out for tacos when it's over
man
yeah and that starts today yeah that's
exactly right starts today
and going back to your original call of
making a budget for the first time
is a great tiny step into what
tomorrow's gonna look like it's
it's a tiny step towards getting control
of your life it's a tiny step towards
saying
you know what i'm a person of value i'm
gonna learn how to do intentionality i'm
gonna learn some new tools about how to
make relationships
and it's going to start with making a
budget today right yeah i'm i'm
we're going to send you a copy of the
book the total money makeover we're
going to show you how to do all this
stuff
um and you know we're going to walk with
you so you call us back if you need some
more help
but you know let's tell the truth the
truth is you can't afford it
and you need to make the purchase just
like you can afford
to go to school and graduate and you
make the purchase
and then you follow through why because
you're actually worth that
and um then you don't make choices over
your health and put you in a completely
different role
hey brother you call anytime we're here
to help you this is the ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five thank you for joining
us america we're so glad you're with us
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
michael and mindy are with us hey guys
how are you
hey we're great welcome where do you
guys live we're just north of seattle
and ever washington
very fun and here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off
one million one hundred thousand dollars
oh wow
and how long did this take about eight
years goodness gracious and your range
of income during that time started at
about 150 and went to
350-ish depending on the year goodness
gracious what do y'all do for a living
i sell real estate and i'm a high school
english teacher
awesomeness okay wow what in the world
what kind of me
did you pay off your house yeah we paid
off um
our home as well as for rental
properties wow
looking at weird people
congratulations and we met at the break
so you're in real estate elp right
you're one of our endorsed local
providers excellent
i love it well done well done well done
congratulations so what in the world put
you on this journey
eight years ago well
we um tried some other methods we
learned about uh
leveraged investing so buying real
estate and getting mortgages and things
of that nature
which was all well and good until well
they had a problem and we had one
particular property we called the pasco
fiasco
and um we ended up in about 60 000
of debt after two floods and uh somebody
set it on fire
oh my god and at that point when the
when the bank wouldn't loan us any money
anymore we decided we needed to try
something different
our insurance person actually said
listen
uh before you call us about this
property again please make sure that
no walls are standing
don't call us again other than that you
can almost feel him winking at you
through the phone that's right
that's right he says don't say i said
this if it's on fire throw gas
oh my gosh wow but you
pushed through eight years yep
yeah we we i think we found you shortly
after that and went through the
financial peace program and it was like
oh
okay we gotta get we gotta get serious
about this
so uh it was it was really you sold that
property i assume
oh yeah that was the relief right there
was a huge relief when that one went
absolutely okay and that got rid of a
bunch of the debt how much of the debt
was that
that wasn't very much of the debt at all
that was only about a hundred thousand
oh okay
um that's the only one we sold and we
had enough income we could have sold
them off and you know whatever to do it
faster but we had enough income and
ability and we wanted to have the
rentals long term
we figured we may as well just pay them
off and i did the math and figured it
wouldn't actually take us all that long
so
we did the long haul wow eight years
though that's real yeah
just plunking along plunking along one
at a time they go away and then the
house goes away or your house goes away
and then one of them goes away out
whatever
basically debt snowballed are all of our
mortgages so we paid the smallest one
first just like if it were a regular
debt and then just paid through the
whole thing
yeah so what was it like navigating this
journey making the income you were
making
yet not living the life that you would
think somebody making
you know a quarter of a million dollars
should be living
for us it's pretty normal um we're not
big extravagant people
okay um you know we don't need a ton of
stuff i mean we have
a lot of kids so we had a lot of kid
expenses but other than that i mean
we're okay to live on just the regular
stuff
um and for homes yeah and for us it's
more long-term planning and just kind of
paying stuff off and putting ourselves
in a place to be able to
have a ton of fun in retirement and live
like no one else wow so
what do you think i mean this is
obviously a huge number 1.1 million we
don't usually get that
um and uh but it's also eight years so
it's quite a slog
so what what is the difference in that
and just knocking off some credit card
debt in one year or something
there's a lot of difference emotionally
and everything else but what do you
think the secret was that enabled you to
stay with it that long
and plow through a number that big i
i mean i think that part of it is it
became a lifestyle right it's it's
there's a part of the beginning where
it's like this is hard
this is really hard because it's new
it's a new kind of way of doing things
we got to be serious about this
and now it's kind of just the way we do
things
and it's just the way we expect it to be
and hopefully we're you know we're
giving that to our kids to say
this is how you handle money this is
this is the expectation
going forward yeah wow and we took a
little bit i mean once we paid because
we borrowed
i mean when we had those issues and we
took out that 60 grand
i mean we borrowed against our car that
had been paid off we took out a personal
loan we borrowed from friends i mean i
had my mom go to the bank and borrow
money for me so i could pay her back
because they wouldn't loan me any more
money
so we were really serious during that
first time i mean i was putting stuff
back at the grocery store doing all the
really hard stuff
after we paid off all the
non-non-mortgage or the non-mortgage
debt
at that point we got a little bit looser
we would start to go on vacations and do
things like that so we could have done
it faster um but we didn't want to kill
ourselves and so we gave ourselves a
little bit of freedom and
had some fun in the meantime well you're
supposed to at this stage
this this baby step is not intense this
baby step is intentionality yeah
right and so you're supposed to have a
rhythm to it and so
very well done you guys how does it feel
to own that much stuff completely
debt-free
it feels good it feels real good it's
not bad dave it's not bad at all
but i did buy we bought our first one uh
our first investment cash
all right and so um that feels really
good we're super excited about that
and um you know they rented it out we're
going to get our first check in like a
month so we're super
super excited it feels way better wished
i hadn't done that the way it should be
right yeah these things cash flow when
they don't have debt on
right they make money it's nice i got a
bunch of them i love it
and then you can buy another one with
all that money and another one with all
that money it's just it snowballs in the
right direction then
yep so well done you guys so very proud
of you who were your biggest
cheerleaders
probably each other yeah honestly you
weren't telling a lot of people this sin
it's a big long run not a ton there's
not a lot of people that can relate when
you're
at a certain level um and you know
things of that nature so i mean we
mostly just kind of
talked about it we did our you know
monthly meetings and you know things of
that with our
with our um budgets and everything else
under the sun and just kind of kept
going
and i'd say early on it was you you were
the cheerleader right you were you know
speaking into that
um because we were listening and and
doing the program so
we really appreciate all the things that
that you were helped with we're so proud
of you guys you're heroes man you did it
i'm so
so well done so very well done well
congratulations and you brought the
kiddos with you what are their names and
ages
so we have christopher who's 17 caleb
and macy are
15. uh maya is eight and arya is seven
all right very cool very cool
we got a whole choir out here i love it
it's great too they look awesome
all right very fun all right michael and
mindy 1.1 million paid off in
eight years we gotta copy a legacy
journey for you because that's
definitely what you're the
phase you're in is leaving a legacy and
an extra copy of total money makeover
for you to give away and pay it forward
so
thank you guys for making the trip all
the way we're so proud of you and so
honored to endorse you as elps as well
thank you so thank you guys so much
michael and mindy 1.1 million paid off
in eight years 150 to 350
income count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
three two one
[Music]
you guys are amazing
so so very proud of you excellent job
way to go that's a lot of money that's a
lot of money
and real estate people in particular are
i mean i grew up in real estate
household i'm a real estate guy i mean
i've had my license since i was 18.
uh we in particular don't that
genre of human doesn't think much about
debt they don't worry about that
and so for them to flip that switch and
go i'm getting out that's a big deal
yeah that's a big deal man i mean you
just gotta
and and then they go through a huge pile
of it and they got all this property now
making money
yeah now this is gonna it's gonna flip
it's raining on them so fast
yeah that and go the other direction so
quickly gonna be absolutely amazing
now very very powerful the hat is
wonderful smiling kids
man that's the legacy right there man
changing a family tree
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america we're
so glad you're with us dr john deloney
ramsey personality is my co-host today
thanks for being with us are you tired
of feeling stuck
with your money like you'll never get
out of debt or save enough for the
future well it doesn't have to be that
way
you can make progress with your money
and faster than you think
but the only way to make it happen is
with a budget that's why you need
a ramsey plus membership you get access
to the premium version of our every
dollar budgeting app
as well as financial peace university
you plan out every dollar you'll need to
spend or
save before the month begins and you
connect your budget to your bank so you
never miss a transaction
custom budget reports this thing is the
best
budgeting app on the planet and it's all
part of ramsey plus
and when you budget you get intentional
with your money you will make
progress really fast and you can start
budgeting for free today
to start your free trial of ramsey plus
text trial 233
789 that's trial two three three
seven eight nine thank you for joining
us america
james is with us in san diego hi james
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave ambassador d how are you guys
great man what's up
hey um i had a question for you
um i'm currently uh in work in
agriculture
and i'm a manager for one of the large
farms in our area
and about five years ago i started a
business on the side and it's
become pretty successful and
my question is is i'm looking at having
a profit in my business around
200 thousand at the end of the year um
and i'm wondering what to do with that
money if i and that's after retained
earnings
of around two hundred thousand and so um
i'm trying to figure out what to do with
the money if i should i had three
options come to mind
and uh one of those would be to pay off
my house
or use it to pay off my house another
would be to
open a step ira and then the last one
would be maybe put in an account to save
to purchase
farm ground so i just want to get your
thoughts on that
okay well before i purchase farm ground
i pay off my house
and i'm assuming you're debt-free other
than your home
i'm debt free other than the home in the
business and personally
other than a home and a business what do
you owe on the business
i don't know anything on the business
the business is debt-free as well oh
okay
i misunderstood the way you phrased that
okay and all right so you're 100
dead free not counting your mortgage
good and you have other savings i assume
yes the business currently has around
200 and
000 in retained earnings yeah and do you
have a person
you have a personal emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
yes good okay that's what we call baby
step three
you're out of debt and you have your
emergency fund then the next thing you
would do is make sure you're putting 15
percent of your household income away
for retirement so that might involve the
sep
the next thing is kids college that's
baby step five i'd begin to work on that
if that applies in this situation
and then baby step six is pay off your
house so that's going to lead us pretty
quickly to paying off your house
what do you owe on your home
a little bit under 300 000. okay
so you would pay it off how if you had
200 coming out of the business
all right well i mean i've just jumped
down on it i wouldn't be able to pay it
off completely
you could if you pulled a hundred out of
retained earnings
well i'm and because of uh being in
agriculture i don't get paid very uh
i get paid very sporadically so i
there's a lot of times i have to cash
flow
out of that 200 000 maybe 100 000 a
month at times and then sometimes less
than that
you know but that's only two months then
sometimes
well but i mean one month might be a
hundred thousand but then it on on
average
it averages out to about 200 000 for six
months oh okay
all right so that's that's that's
setting you up to keep the business
running then all right that's not
it's not free retained earnings it's our
already spoken for i got you
okay that makes sense well no what yeah
well it's above what i normally
i don't have to touch it most of the
time because of what's coming in but if
it was
a catastrophic something i got you know
something happened and i
lost you know that it would be a kind of
an emergency fund for the business i
don't normally touch it
okay well i'm i'm moving towards paying
off the house as fast as i possibly can
so if you chunk it on the house then
we need to find that other hundred
pretty quick and get that house finished
off that's my only goal here
but yeah that's the answer is i'm gonna
pay it right down the line on that that
would be the game plan
so dave uh talk to me about
what's retained earnings savings account
in business oh okay
and so he's using it for an emergency
fund or in his case
but obviously it's um you know it's more
than just a rainy day fund
uh and for business you can use it for
expanding
you could use it for buying another
business or buying a piece of equipment
you could use it for
covering a cash flow drain which is what
he's worried about he's worried about
a situation where he continues to have
to write checks but doesn't have the
money to do it and yes you have some
money to do that or you go in debt
is there a is there a tax break or
something for calling and retained
earning versus savings
it's just a fancy way of saying savings
account no i get tax day every year on
it okay
whatever i add to my business savings
account the irs considers it personal
money okay and i get to pay taxes on it
so it is reduced by tax amount every
year
yeah it's it's no fun at all yeah that's
the part where they love small
businesses and we always laugh
you know when you say congress loves
small business horse crap
no but by hanging on to some money to
make sure your business continues to run
you get taxed on holding it yeah yeah
that's exactly right
i didn't take it home buy something with
it i left it in here to keep it running
keep all these jobs afloat but i get to
pay taxes on it
so that's yeah that's bogus but it's
been that way
always so that's not going to change
jessica is with us jessica's in
jacksonville
florida hi jessica welcome to the ramsay
show
hi dave and dr d um
my question is i've been feeling um kind
of lost after
separation from um husband and i'm back
in my hometown
and i just feel lost
separation from husband are you divorced
uh i i'm having a hard time pulling the
trigger on that one and
we were about to sign the papers and we
even had you know paid the lawyer and
just had the pen to the paper and just
kind of
said well let's just do the separation
first kind of thing so we're just doing
that first
and then probably be divorced before the
end of the year
so what what's the of course you're
going to feel lost because you've you're
in this limbo now
why did you decide to hang on for a
second even though you sounds like you
already know where this
where this how the story ends
i'm not sure everything was so hard to
let go of like you know when you got
you know your kidney you got the tooth
that's coming out and some of them come
out just real
clean with the no blood and then you got
the one that's just
really bloody it was just so it is like
the second one just
felt real emotional and messy and i
don't know just having a real hard time
letting go both of us but
so why'd you decide to get divorced um
just certain lifestyle choices that my
husband's making kind of um
and so kind of pushed me into the corner
of having to do it
and everything and it's it's just hard
to
let go um so why don't you trust jessica
i don't know i think because yeah i
um i feel i feel like a like a loser
like i can't do anything right like no
choice i make
is right i try and try to make the right
choice and
everything kind of turned out wrong all
the time
so one of the most not everything i i do
make some good you know choices
one of the most devastating things when
a relationship um
is is falling apart when someone's
making choices that
impacts the other impacts you know their
wife or their husband someone
cheats on somebody someone steals or
does something that
um starts to melt a relationship
we often you know mourn the loss of that
relationship but
the part that goes unspoken for is that
we also lose
trust in ourselves i thought i was wise
and how did i make this decision
and so jessica you're gonna feel
untethered until you
put a period at the end of this sentence
and you can begin moving on with your
life
now
[Applause]
and anytime you stump your toe and you
fall down and your hands get scratched
you wonder if you know how to walk that
would be a normal human reaction to lose
some confidence
so you're not as dumb as you feel like
you are right this second
the opposite nowhere near it you're very
wise this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker
just tell alexa google assistant or siri
to play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where that is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john dolone
ramsey personality is my co-host today
thank you for joining us america we're
so glad
you are here open phones at triple eight
eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight
two five five two two five
rosa is with us in london england to
start this hour off hi rosa how are you
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
thanks for taking my call i'm such a big
fan um so i'll
um i'll ask my question and then give
you context i'm in the middle of buying
a house in london
and i'm having second thoughts and
thinking of pulling out because
of my lifestyle and i'm newly engaged
and i'd love to know what you would do
in my situation
so i'm an actress so my life is very
nomadic which means i spent like i spend
several months per year
abroad for work but all of my family and
friends
are in london and i've always wanted a
base here and i like
to have a place to call home when i've
been away for so many months
but now i i've just got engaged my
fiance's
based in canada so our aim is to move to
la
um so would you still purchase a
small property in london in my situation
and also even if i am based in la i'll
probably end up working in london a lot
anyway
i'd love your opinion thank you wow
this sounds so sophisticated
i feel unqualified to answer your call
based on everything you just said
just because you sound more smart and
more lovely and just
more just a better person yeah i don't
know she's a better person than you are
i could i could feel it through the
telephone line oh that's hilarious
okay so um what will your household
income be in a given year on average
um the last three years it's ranged from
500
000 to 50 000 so let's say an average
let's be conservative an average of like
150.
okay so that'd be like a bad year yeah
and uh that's just you or your fiance
that's just me what does he make um
on average i'd say a hundred okay so a
bad year is a quarter of a million
and you're going to buy a home to live
in in l.a
and what would the what to live i said
la is our
well eventually once we get to l.a we
would love to buy a home together
combining finance yeah
but right now um right now london is
where i'm from so i'd always wanted
like a song i got that part but i'm
saying your your marriage
home base will be
la because this is where you're going to
combine your lives
and then london is like where you are
from
obviously and you spent a lot of time
there so that's like your second home
yes okay and what would you spend on the
second home
um the place i put in an offer for but i
can still back out of obviously it's 375
pounds have you got the cash
yes okay and i've i've i've been i've
been debt-free all my life i think i've
kind of been following your plan without
knowing it and now i found you i'm so
excited
okay well here's the way i would look at
it i'm going to kind of reverse engineer
this a little bit
let's pretend i'm talking to a couple
that's making a quarter of a million to
a half a million and they live in la
and they want to buy a second home for
375 000 cash in london because they
spend a lot of time there because of her
family
can i phrase it that way it's still the
same thing isn't it
yes so this is like someone in the
states calling me and saying i want to
buy a beach house
it's a second home in a sense it's a toy
uh my kids were in college in a in a
town
in a city uh several hundred miles from
here
and i bought a condominium there because
we were gonna spend a lot of time there
going to football games and
seeing our kids there so it's that kind
of a thing right
yeah so this falls under the heading of
it's a toy it's a second home
yes you can buy it if you can afford it
based on your income and if you can pay
cash for it
so you happen to be doing it backwards
because right now it's home but it's not
always going to be home much longer
yeah and so would you say yes i would
buy it to only
but if i don't buy it cash like say i
chose to save some of my money
i would not buy it unless you pay cash
for it okay
if you called me and you lived in l.a
and said i want to buy a house in
uh cancun or in martinique as a
beach house uh but i want to go into
debt to do it i would tell you don't
don't do that i would say pay cash for
it or don't buy a toy because a second
home
is a toy and even though this doesn't
feel emotionally like a second home
because you're leaving there
and it has been your home it's going to
function
in your new life as a second home and so
i'm gonna treat it like it's a beach
house a vacation house a lake house a
mountain house or whatever uh in this
case it just happens to be in london
and so um i've got friends that live in
la and they've got
um apartments that they own in in new
york city because they're back and forth
they're by coastal they're back and
forth all the time
and they buy it just so they can not
have to screw with hotels and stuff and
they've got the money
you know and so but it's a second home
it's not a
it is not a necessity of life you could
go back and
the times you're back there you could
just rent an apartment and it wouldn't
kill you
and rosa if you and i had an hour to sit
down and
talk through this a little bit deeper
the next question i would ask and this
isn't for this show
is something i see dave often when
people are about to get married
is they want to go stake uh put a
[ __ ]
flag in the in the ground back where
home was trap door
just escape just in case it's the escape
hack i need to make sure that i don't
lose my roots because i'm about to go
tether to somebody else and i need to
hang in there
with that in mind it might be okay not
to buy it and that's it
almost got the sense that rose was
asking for permission to not buy it
and do i not need it but either way
know that going into to marriage it's a
safety valve you are
joining forces with somebody okay all
right and not having this little purpose
of this
is just to come back and visit i'm gonna
take
that happens a lot right uh i'm gonna
i'm gonna invest in this small little
business back in my hometown or with my
old high school buddy or whatever the
thing happens to me when people are
about to get married
it just feels to go all in so marriage
is
you are pushing your chips across the
table i'm all in
that is really insightful i have not
thought of that that's
very very interesting did not hear that
in her voice at all
uh but that's a possibility because the
way she did alfred up three or four
times not to do it
and and i don't want to pay cash and and
i'm gonna
i would it's gonna be my money for my
little thing because then we're gonna
get married and move to oh
and i get that i get it i get it i get
it it's like keeping the old bachelor
pad
that's exactly right i'm gonna keep
paying rent on this little place yeah
um wow oh very cool but you can you can
man there's so many tethers when you're
about to get married dave right
there's so many well and that's uh
there's so much going on i mean you got
canada uk
and la all mixed together and a
transient job right where you're moving
everywhere
where you're already gypsified
inhabiting other people for a living
right
what a fun life just an incredible life
inviting other people into your body
that's what it is man
you have to become somebody's zombie
body snatcher so
great that's interesting that's
interesting not a call we get on the
show very often
but you know what i'm not going to lie
that touch of sophistication i think
helped the show a little bit interesting
i'm saying we just need a good i'm gonna
tell you what's getting a good english
accent a good australian accent at least
once a week
kelly can you arrange that for us just
make sure you get a caller on that
sounds smarter than we are fairly often
oh wait a minute
no comments no comments from the booth
we've had 10 of those
comments from the food this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching
to pure top just go to feartalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
ever asked a question how much money
should i be saving how much
debt can i pay off how can i pay off
debt faster what's the right way to
invest investing scares me hey here's
the good news you don't have to figure
out the answers to this on your own
ramsay plus will guide you every step of
the way with ramsey plus membership you
get the digital teaching that you need
with financial peace university to
really understand money
so you can be confident you're always
doing the next
right thing plus our world-class
budgeting app tools and guided action
steps to help you make progress on your
money goals
fast it means no more debt cash in the
bank for emergencies and a real plan for
your future
ramsey plus helps you get small
consistent wins
every day that lead to big results and
lifelong habits
to get started today with a free trial
text trial to 33789
that's trial to 33 789
dr john deloney ramsey personality is
our co-host today
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal
all right today's question comes from
jennifer in alabama
jennifer writes our daughter has been
struggling with
college for a couple of years she's
seeing a therapist for anxiety and
depression
she recently decided to drop out of
school and work full-time
she refuses to move back home and wants
to keep the car we provided her for
school
we told her to come home figure out her
next steps and give the car back
or she can finish school and keep the
car she sees this as a punishment and
thinks we are unsupportive villains
any advice on how to keep a 21 year old
who seems to have already
already made up their mind
dave you're a dad who's had a couple of
three or four 21 year olds
i've got some man
this one gets under my skin a little bit
so you go first
um i don't think
jennifer that you're involved enough in
her
situation emotionally
uh to meet out of this boundary
it sounds like you don't believe that
she has anxiety and depression and she's
just screwing around and so you're gonna
punish her for screwing around
um that's the way this sounds to me so
if you're acting on that then that's
okay if she really has anxiety and
depression and you really believe she
does
then you're completely out of line give
her the car help her
she's trying to find her way through a
real tough mental situation
and you know but i i think you guys are
pretty detached from her emotionally is
what it feels like yeah the note i wrote
is this is a relationship issue right
now
yeah and you're trying to flex on a 21
year old who's struggling
and sometimes for a college student
with obviously with high expectations
and high family support to say
i'm gonna take a break that's a hard
brave move
it's not always the best and sometimes
people are into drugs and crazy but
sometimes it's a hard brave move
and this looks like well then you can
just
fill in the blank and you know what as a
parent you can do that it's your car you
can do that
and i've said your question was how to
help her that's right the question was
not
what should i should i take her car away
the question was how do i help her
that's right
and if this is my kid i'm going to get
on the next bus or get in my car
and we're going to go have a meal
together and say i'm i'm
something here tells me this is a long
time coming
and um there's a there's a deeply
fractured relationship
it's just hard to hit somebody in the
back of the head unless you got your arm
around their shoulder
you know and it feels like that you're
trying to punch from over here not from
your not from your arm around the
shoulder yeah um
and with somebody struggling and they
say hey i need to take a step back and
your first thought your first response
is
then you need to do what i say that's
hard yeah it's hard
and at the same time i want to be clear
this is your car come get it
but it may cost you your daughter yeah
your question was not
what your rights are your question was
how can i
um help guide
a 21 year old who's already made up
their mind right
um i think i you know
i'm going to do a i i'm reading a lot
between the lines it's hard to know in
this situation
but i'm reading a lot between the lines
that your relation your emotional
connectivity and relationship with her
is not deep enough to make the to make
to to she's not listening to you
and that tells me you don't have enough
connectivity for her you're not
persuading
anymore you're just you're just hitting
with a bat you're not even a safe place
enough a safe enough place to come home
when she's falling apart right she's got
to go find somewhere else
we we talk a lot about boomerang kids
who can't wait to run back to mom and
dad
and you know there's a whole industry
about teaching mom and dad how to draw
boundaries
but kids think that mom and dad are safe
in that situation your kid's struggling
and she doesn't you are not a place that
she can even be around now she wants to
keep your car fair enough
you're not a place that she can go and
that's where the car the car doesn't
matter
no that's what i think um the advice on
how to help guide her is spend more time
with her
right and this looks like help guides
him to listen more and talk less how do
i flex more
yeah how do i listen more and talk less
and
um gain the
emotional proximity earn the right
to persuade and guide and that's
creating you've lost you've lost this
right that's what we're both seeing
she's lost the right to persuade yeah
that's what amounts to for sumps through
something we don't know what
and my guess is this is a long time it
could be the kid yeah it could be the
kid but somehow you lost the right to
persuade so
keep the car don't keep the car i don't
give a rip about the car um but get in
your car and go
sit down and meet you if it's not an
expensive car just go to her i wouldn't
give her any more money
until we've got these things repaired
she's a 21 21 year old making a 21 year
old grown-up decision so she can go make
her 21 year old
life yeah i'll go along with that and
i'm not going to support
things that i don't have that i can't
speak into uh so if you're gonna wall me
out
for whatever reason my fault or your
fault then i'm not gonna throw money in
over the wall that's not uh that that's
just uh
that's enabling on a steroids but but if
you throw the car into the mix and then
use that
as a leverage to just start to rebuild a
higher quality relationship to
persuade that's your only help i think
as a dad
of kids grump having grown kids is the
most difficult version of kid raising
kids i mean
because you no longer get to tell them
what to do no you have to persuade them
and so i have to sit with my son who's
getting ready to turn 30 and talk him
into stuff like i have to talk you into
stuff
you know i can't just make you do well i
can as your boss but then
it's the same thing it's a temporary
thing so i have to persuade
adults in my life to do things that are
even for their own good
whether they're my kids as adults or
other people's kids as adults and so
you just cannot you and it was just
easier when i said you have to do that
because i said so
i read a line the other day dave that
i'm still processing in it and when i
hear a line like this i'll sit on it for
a while
but here was the line i want to be the
kind of father that when something
happens to my child he doesn't think
oh crap we can't tell dad
we can't let dad find out i want to be
the kind of dad that when something
happens to my kid he says oh crap we
better find dad
we better call dad and not that that
means that
we're not going to hold people
accountable but i want to be the
the sentiment behind this is i want to
be a safe enough place that my kid
trusts me that when things get sideways
i'm going to walk alongside them
and i haven't wrapped my head around
that yet dad may kill me but he'll help
me first
that's right that's right that's right
that's the dad i want to be i do want
the threat of death over them
he'll do it quick and painless right
this one's going to be slow and
miserable right yeah
yeah but there's something about
building that safety as a parent that
i'm going to hold you accountable but
you're never
ever going to doubt that i love you yeah
and that's a hard balance right yeah
that's exactly right it's a and i think
it's even harder the older they get
yeah when they're three you know you
just make them do stuff
is it okay so let me ask you this dave
is it hard because you have a desired
future
for them or is it hard because because i
like people doing what i tell them to do
yeah you're letting the control go
right that seems to be the hard part
yeah i mean we all do oh no it's like i
told you
you know listen if you turn left there
you're going you're not going to get the
where you're going you need to turn
right yeah it's and then i have to then
when they go around the block six times
i told you
you know it's like you keep driving a
car like that you're gonna wreck it you
know you keep
driving your life like that you're going
to wreck it and sure enough they do
you know and but uh you can't and the
only way we learn stuff is about
wrecking the card
no it's not the only way you can watch
other people i know
you can listen to your own man who
wrecked a bunch of cars and knows better
you know you don't have to go broke to
learn to not do what i did to go broke
you can you can
you can do better and uh thank goodness
oh my goodness parenting a little too
much authenticity
here on this segment of the show this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
daniel and sarah are with us hey guys
how are you hi we're good how are you
wonderful
welcome welcome good to have you so
where do you guys live
bowling green kentucky ah an hour and a
quarter away
that's right yes sir that's right i took
delivery on a new corvette
at the museum and did the tour of the
plant and a week later the museum caved
in
so you got to did you get to come back
and see our sinkholes i saw the sinkhole
right before it happened i was standing
over the top of it
and a week later i was like i could have
been in that hole yeah
it said they put it all back it's
supposed to be beautiful i haven't been
back up since they did it it is it's
gorgeous for those of you that don't
know the corvette
plant is in bowling green kentucky and
the corvette museum
is in bowling green kentucky and i don't
know what was that five six years ago i
guess
i think so sinkhole swallowed up half of
the museum all these
vintage vets are in this hole for those
of you not watching
on youtube dave has a tear in his eye
just talking about definitely
i'm completely sidetracked here these
poor people came to do a debt free
screening i'm talking about
so how much debt have you guys paid off
we paid off 101
240 dollars i like it and how long did
this take
12 months wow and your range of income
during that time
about 144 to about 180 that's a nice
jump in 12 months
and what kind of debt was the 101 um
we had some cell phones hvac units
student loans a jeep lease which i
didn't know it was leased at first
and then um i had bought a small house
the day
after our first date and we had a
foundation
repair okay so what was the big one
um the small house after our first date
yeah the biggest was um
such a great line bought a small house
right after our first thing
again for those of you are watching
there's a story here i'm just saying he
said
jeep lease you looked at him as though i
still might kill him
and then you mentioned the small house
shabbat well you know i really didn't
know that we were going to get married
and so i was looking for a place for
myself to live so i purchased a really
like a really small house i was going to
be able to walk to work
i was going to get a small dog i was
going to eat thai food every day i just
had this whole plan
you know i have a corolla i'm happy with
it
[Laughter]
he carries the corolla yes so fun y'all
so okay so what was the big number out
of the 101 um
the small house was about 48 000. okay
and then
you paid it off or did you sell it we
sold it okay all right good that helped
you move it that much in a year
well yeah that 48 came off you know of
course immediately but
the money that we got from the sale of
the house was basically my down payment
back
and during the middle of our debt
snowball we learned that we had a
foundation repair and so that was about
30 grand extra oh
so we um you know selling that in the
101 or an audition no that was an
addition because that wasn't a debt we
just cash flowed that
okay wow it was a yeah like this
is a test yes right in the middle of it
you have to have to not lose your mind
yes yeah way to go guys okay so how long
you've been married
um about a year and a half okay so not
long end of the marriage you said we're
gonna clean this all up
yes you put it all in a pile both of you
brought your stuff in put in the middle
of the kitchen table and said oh crap
and tell me the story what happened well
actually
um i lost my first wife in 2019
and she did not have any life insurance
or anything
so i had tons of debt
you know to take care of at that point
sure and um
you know i there was a lot of times
where i didn't know if i was gonna be
able to buy groceries
you know it was it was a tough time and
then not long
after that her aunt who i am
i used to work with called me up and
like hey you know would you uh
my my uh niece sarah i just want to know
if you want to go out with her and i
said
heck yeah i remember her from high
school i had a crush on her in high
school
so you know we've been on our short
squat with me yeah exactly that was
that was exactly you know my first
thought so you know we went out we
hit it off great and then you know after
my second or third date i had a huge
interview with her like she was asking
me everything
he calls our dates job interviews yeah
because i mean you know how
you know how much debt you have you know
you know what what's your plan
i was running down numbers i'm a nerd
believe it or not
what kind of plans are you doing so you
know once we
you know once we got married she's a big
dave ramsey fan she's been you know
listening to
to you for years and years and so she
kind of got me on board with
wanting to do this now she was debt free
before except for the little house
you know before i came in the picture
and then i just screwed it all up okay
no no she brought half of this in there
yeah
48 of the 101 yes so you split it down
the middle you just
it just came about it differently you
might call one a little smarter than the
other but you had a tragedy too
yes so yeah that makes it the whole
process so the good news is in 12 months
you did it
so how does your income go up 40 000 in
one year
um you know i had a child when i was 20
and so being a young mom work is not
anything i'm scared of so
i picked up a second job and
the company that i work for was offering
some bonus money
and some incentives to go help at a
hospital in pennsylvania so i took as
many of those assignments as i could get
even spent the entire christmas holiday
working in pennsylvania in a hospital
just you know
and that really put us over the finish
line and then um
also he sold everything that even stuff
that was nailed down
like i got home from work one day and he
said uh did you notice that everything's
off the walls i was like
because i just don't care about things
like that and so he had taken everything
off the walls and it was sold
whoa and when we were combining
households we just sold everything we
took a bunch of stuff to goodwill
um he was a little nervous about cutting
cable but we cut cable we cut satellite
radios
oh my goodness we cut the gym membership
which was interesting because he had me
work like
use me as a piece of workout equipment
one day and i was like what is
this about um what else did we do
we shopped all of our insurance to make
sure we were getting the best rates on
everything
um gosh we you know just
literally everything you teach we just
want you to dial down every little
every little corner to make it work yeah
for me so when you look back on it the
two of you and someone comes up to you
and they say
how do you get out of debt in 12 months
what do you tell them the main thing
they have to do is
to me you both have to be on the same
page
you have to work together if you've got
one person that's 100 percent in and the
other one's not it's not going to work
out very well
and we were both there we both wanted it
bad
you know and especially me and i felt so
bad that you know
i know we both brought dead in there but
i just felt so bad that she had to be
part of my debt but we're married
you know we put our accounts together
which we've never done in our previous
relationships so you know it just it
worked out god centered to me at the
right time
and it was perfection wow hey you know
what
he sent her to you too man oh yes he did
right
yes um you know he was the he was the
answer to so many prayers
yeah and here's what's cool one of the
biggest challenges with when
when folks get married and they've had
previous relationships one of the
hardest parts
is how do we get on this how do we find
a new path
right i've got this path experience hey
man y'all launched out of the gate on a
100 000 gazelle intense mission
yes and now you you guys forged a path
you're just looking better locked
man you just blaze the trail through the
forest with you just put your head down
and he's a good guy to get behind right
because yes
he is over that head you all cleared a
path
and now you're off to the races right
you know a funny story you know
i have a 20 year old daughter and he has
a 14 year old daughter
and um it was a december of 2019
the youngest daughter wanted to get her
ears pierced and she had plenty of money
to do it so we took her to the mall
and when we get to the mall she starts
crying she wants daddy to pay for it and
she's got her own money so i said no you
know you've got your no money you can
pay for this
then she tries to negotiate well i'll
pay you back later or can you pay half
of it and i'll pay half of it and so the
crying went on and on and on
and finally he leans over and he
whispers you know should i just pay for
it so i you know took this big hand and
i was like no
we're going to get through this like
this is a this is a teacher she's 14.
is she crying about this this is a
teachable moment but
since that time we put her through the
homeschool curriculum and so she's got
her own
she's got her emergency fund she's uh
she's working for commission to do
chores it's
you know we've just we're changing
everything absolutely i'm so proud of
y'all we got a copy of legacy journey
and total money makeover for you 101
thousand dollars paid off daniel and
sarah bowling green kentucky they did it
in 12 months making 144 to 180 what a
great
story count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
three two
[Applause]
this is how you do it baby touchdown
how fun it's so fun what a great love
story
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
i'm dave ramsey open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
jessica is in lancaster pennsylvania hi
jessica how are you
i'm doing great dave thank you for
taking my call it's an honor to speak to
you
you too what's up so um i
i have a question about some inheritance
that i received when my dad passed away
um my sister was purposefully written
out of the will
and i have always wanted to i think it's
the right thing to share something with
her but
i don't agree with the way she's
financially lived her life and the
decisions she's made
so i do not want to give her cash the
decision i made was to have some money
set aside for
wedding whenever she gets married and to
make a one-time
principal payment on her student loan
that she's been carrying
and she now thinks it's a waste for me
to make that payment
and she thinks you'll agree with her
which i know you won't
um why was she why was she cut out of
the wheel
um the relationship between her and my
dad fell apart years ago and
i believe my dad's stubbornness led it
to not
getting repaired okay
that's so sad yeah yes i know it how
long has he been gone
five years how old are you and how old
is she
i'm 46 and she's 43. and um and
obviously you guys have a pretty good
relationship
yes we do okay and how much money are
you talking about
i i want to make a 20 000 payment
towards your student loan
and out of how much money did you
receive
um i think about 150 total
okay all right there's a part of you
that
is act feels somewhat maternal towards
her
that you don't trust her to make good
decisions
and so you're gonna you're gonna give
her you're gonna give her a gift because
it's the right thing to do but you're
gonna direct how it
if it feels like a weird relational
dynamic for between sisters is is
is that she's responsible with money
right um
is that is there a discomfort there
between the two of you said she was
gonna say that was a waste of a gift
well yes because the direction she's
going is
she's she's not doing anything to pay it
off with any urgency she's just writing
it out
until it gets to 25 years thinking the
balance will be
forgiven because of an income based
repayment plan
and what i'm offering to give her and
what she would pay over the next
13 years so that happens would not total
the
total balance of the loan
okay well there's a lot of things going
on here
um first let's just talk about the
public service
student loan forgiveness program as of
today
the last night i'm sorry she's not even
public service
loan forgiveness why does she feel oh
she just feels like in general it's
going to be forgiven
yeah she found something online that
says the the income based repayment plan
when the loan
yeah it hasn't been so far 227 000
people have applied for
student loan forgiveness under these
programs 3
700 out of 200 000 have gotten it
that's less than one percent
and so um her she's um
uh she believes a lie about
getting out of student loan debt so
that's that's one piece of information
so
in that sense um you know we
we've got other problems with her
student loan other than
whether you give her money or whether
she pays it off because that student
loan's not going away
unless the biden administration and the
democratic congress decides to forgive
student loan debt
which is possible uh for the first time
in our history
um and uh uh
you know there's obviously a lot of
rhetoric in the last
four or five months uh since the
inauguration about that so
and there's no way to predict what they
will actually do or if they will
do anything other than just talk about
it you know their congress
so um um
normally so uh
normally in a situation like this i i
want to
give because it's something that i think
is the right thing to do
and it always is hard when you come up
against this moment when you think
by by giving the right thing to do i'm
going to enable somebody to hurt
themselves further
is that where you're at jessica or you
just don't like how she's spinning it
i don't want to enable her bad behavior
because she's
obviously not going to put it towards
the loan it will
most likely get at least somewhat wasted
and spent
uh and i really want to
help her yeah if um
yeah is there if we could take the
student loan out of the thing it would
change the equation for me i mean does
she have a car loan or something you can
just pay off
no she doesn't uh this is her only dad
this is her own this is her only dad
is this her only debt as far as i know
yes
okay
and the interesting thing is as you all
have talked about it to where the
language has changed to where now she
feels entitled to it
i know i'm entitled to tell you what to
do with the money you're giving her that
was interesting part of the
thing too yeah so wow
i don't know what to tell you i um i
think i you know here's an idea when in
doubt don't
and just say you know what i want to do
something
to honor you out of this inheritance
because i think you got a raw deal
but i also don't want to participate in
a delusional situation and your student
loan is not i don't think your student
loans going away
um and so how much does she owe
i think 92 and what does she make
she makes now about 60. okay
um you know i i
might offer to match her for
every five thousand dollars she puts on
you'll put five thousand on it
um i like that idea but um but but but
you know
and it's just it's just you and her
talking and you're just saying
i you know you're an adult you have the
right to do what you want to do
sister but but i
also have that and i i cannot
give you money for i agree with you that
giving you money for this is going to
end up being wasted because you're not
going to get it paid off
and then it's going to be a bigger
problem because you think it's going to
go away i don't think it's going to go
away so i really don't want to put the
20 on that and so i don't know how to
give you money
because you're mis because i think what
you're doing with this is irresponsible
and so i love you and i want you to win
and so what we're going to do right now
is nothing i'm just going to sit back
and watch a little bit and
and if you decide you want to get after
the student loan and i'll put some money
towards it with you and i'll help you
but until you do i right now i'm just
gonna watch because i want to do
something but i don't know how to do it
right now and so
what i'm gonna do is wait okay
and in the meantime should i do
something different with it other than
it's just sitting in my face with the
camera bank
yeah well you can do whatever you want i
mean it's not it's you can put in a
mutual fund if you want then you can
pull it out and give it to her but
um later on but it's just the the
biggest thing here is it's just all tied
back to this
heartbreaking relationship between her
and your dad yeah that's the part i
don't like about it dave is
it because dad did what he did
now she's holding this and she's gotta
make one of two choices
either i'm gonna become dad and i'm
going to
use my relational position
and my money to keep you to not share it
with you because of your decisions your
choices
so i'm replaying what just happened no
that's true or
i'm going to give you money knowing that
i'm just throwing this
i'm throwing it in the wind that's right
and so my impulse um
there's always wisdom and they just just
it's just do nothing that's all i said
yeah and then my thought is you know
what i'm saying
i'm free myself from this and
so i it's the same impulse just the
other side which if you feel in your
heart's the right thing
dad did a raw deal the right thing is to
give money the right thing to do is to
give money
and forget it don't worry yeah and
that's what i wanted it's not on you
well it drills down to if someone's if
someone's doing drugs someone's hurting
themselves versus they're gonna go buy a
dumb car
right um but man especially when you're
holding that money you could really help
them with their student loan
it's hard it's just a messy situation
there's a 41 year old
yeah so it might be down to what you're
saying
i don't disagree with your change in
direction on that it's
i just give them the money or i wouldn't
yeah and i just call it
call it yeah i like your advice better
than mine
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality and host of
the
dr john delaney podcast and youtube show
is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
825-5225
haley is in denver our first call this
hour hi haley how are you
doing good thank you um
my husband and i are currently on baby
step number two um
our annual income is about 115 000 per
year
and we have about 75 000 left in debt to
pay off
so i'm thinking that we can be
completely debt free within the next 24
months
amen um and my question is
where do we prioritize family planning
into the baby steps if we're facing an
untraditional path to start our family
through
surrogacy or adoption
uh well there's not a baby in the baby
steps um
you have babies when you're ready to
have babies but you throw a curve in
there when you say there's a different
kind of a cost here
okay and so um
you know i i think uh and the i guess
the other possible
uh question that comes up that's similar
you're not asking that question but this
similar is an in vitro
uh you know when do we do that and i'm
you know i'm 36 and i
i you know i don't want to wait two more
years and that kind of stuff i get that
question over the years a lot
that's in the it's in the same bucket of
questions
um and so uh i i think if you're gonna
do surrogacy
or uh adoption you would do the uh
you would learn so much about these two
things that you would find that there's
a
vast spectrum
that people pay for these things uh
5 000 to 100 000 spectrum
yeah we're seeing about 45 to 60
000 depending on which route we take and
if it's in the united states or
international
and my husband is 35 so age is something
that we're definitely
thinking about yeah i think you've got
more research to do
okay uh we've worked with many many many
families
uh that have done adoptions for half
of your low number or less and so
um i think you're getting uh the bentley
pitch rather than the chevrolet pitch on
the adoption process
so um no it does not it doesn't know it
does not cost that much
and so um i i think you've got you know
here's the thing when i when i the more
information i gather and the more
options i have the more power i have in
making a decision
and i i don't think you have enough
options yet as a matter of fact i'm sure
you don't because the prices you're
quoting me are ridiculous
well that's mainly for our
first choice which would be surrogacy so
that we could have a biological child
the adoption would be secondary okay
which we know we can do cheaper
okay all right and i i you know
obviously there's a lot of ways to
compensate a surrogate and a lot of
price ranges on that as well so
it's such a personal thing and such an
intimate
thing that it's very hard for somebody
on the radio like me to speak into it
and
and not sound callous or not sound like
i don't care about it i do care about it
it it's just you have got you do not
want to get into these situations
and um and and look back later and
and wow that that uh
uh it's so emotional it can cloud you
from treating it like a business
transaction
as much as you should i want it to be
emotional i want it to be intimate i
want it to matter
but i also want you to use wisdom in the
process does that make sense
yeah yeah so i'm not trying to be
unfeeling in other words but
uh but but so anyway uh
i can tell you in our life me and my
wife when we were
walking down some of these steps we put
an end
a line we wouldn't cross because we knew
that once we
um our hearts got into this deal and
once there are people around you
always saying well there's another
option there's another option there's
another option that suddenly you wake up
and you're you're you're so far over
your head or you're so far underwater
it's just the whole thing what was going
to be this joyous precious moment
gets really really cloudy what's the 75
000 in debt
oh my gosh everything
um we have how much of it how much of
its cars
um about 25 000
but last july it was 90. we sold
well we've surrendered two vehicles and
then we're paying off the death assist
on it but we have
two cash cars now oh okay okay
we have two beaters right now so all
right so the 25 is the deficits
yeah correct yes and then the rest is
some debt to
um i have a loan with my parents um
and then credit cards just furniture
how much do you owe your payments what's
that
about twenty thousand okay
all right i you know i i might
you know i might consider uh making that
a pause
point in the rest of the clean up the
rest of that snowball because you do
want the cash to be freed up to be able
to do these other things
so i want you working your death
snowball i want you pushing through the
majority of it but
that 20 i might ask for a moratorium on
that until after the baby
and say mom and dad i'm not going to pay
anything on this because we're going to
get you a grandkid
oh that's a good blackmail and uh
uh but yeah or i mean negotiate that
with them talk to them about it and and
so
um you know that's a different kind of
debt that you could get
uh you know no payments and no interest
while
you work through this other thing and
then come back to it after baby
and get it done that would be fine but
um
the question is not really when to have
babies the questions were to stick a
sixty thousand dollar or forty thousand
dollar or twenty five
000 expense in the middle of your debt
snowball
and it's an expense that is very
intimate very emotional
and um and worth every penny
yeah i would strongly recommend going to
a
counselor that you recommend or a pastor
this is one of those moments where your
pictures and words get screwed up right
we think in
in pictures but we speak in words and
we're both saying baby and we're both
saying kid and we're both saying
pay off the debt and that's when one of
you has one picture the other's got
another one so just
being able to have a third party to walk
you through make sure everybody's on the
same page
where are we headed what do we want to
do here and how what order we're going
to do that man you can't go wrong
getting everybody on the same page yeah
that's important and um and
i agree with what you said earlier too
that you and sheila talked about
you do have to put a line on this uh
because otherwise your emotions will
plow past anything that's reasonable you
look up maybe 150 in
yeah or something and i've i've seen
people with in vitro
where they just break the bank yeah they
just keep going back
and that was my wife's wisdom up front
let's draw a line here let's say this is
this is as far as we're going to take
this
and then we're we're going to work hard
but this is we're not going to cross
this line and i
was that ended up being extraordinary
wisdom as you know as usually
our wives yes absolutely yeah there's
it's just it's one of those things
that's very it's
it's impossible for people or yourself
to tell yourself no one it's just a
if you don't you're going to get in
[Music]
trouble
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today today's the day
to do things you've never done so that
you can get things you've never gotten
this is your chance to learn how to make
faster
and real progress with your money and
other things
when you check out our famous ten dollar
sale get sick and tired of being sick
and tired
well are you trying to get out of debt
our number one best seller total money
makeover is 10 bucks
redefining anxiety by dr john deloney
bestseller
only 10 bucks our life changing books
there's over 40 best sellers on the list
60 off for only a few more weeks there's
something for everyone
whether you're looking for a job
starting a business paying off student
loans teaching your kids about money
there's a book and a plan for you
remember adults devise a plan and follow
it
and if you give like no one else this is
your chance to save 60
off our best-selling books shop our 10
sale at ramseysolutions.com go to
ramseysolutions.com
store and you can get things moving
people
that's simple open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five christoph is with us
in los angeles hi kristoff how are you
better than i deserve how are you doing
mr anthony just the same sir how can i
help
well i'm a fourth year medical student
about to start residency actually in
nashville in one month
i have a hundred thousand dollars in
medical debt um and based on what i'm
training to do i'll be a medical
resident for the next six or seven years
making 60 to 70k per year however when
i'm done training and become an
attending physician i'll be making
330 to 500k my question is that
with the knowledge that i can easily you
know more easily write a check for a
hundred thousand dollars
in you know seven or eight years should
i make minimum payments
now to be able to live comfortably uh
such as living close to work having my
own apartment versus having roommates
do you think that i'll be you know in an
intense uh
residency program working 80 hours a
week or should i be
really aggressive right now at the
expense of being able to live more
comfortably
man off top of my head i'm going to be
real aggressive right now i don't know
what the world's going to look like in
eight years man
yeah i would get it i agree agree i'll
get it off of me
and here's the thing here's what's
running through my head
it let's pretend that you just called me
up and you said i make seventy thousand
dollars a year
and i have a hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt
and that's all you said and that's all
it was because there wasn't a 330 000
job out there you made 70 000 a year and
you had a hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt
uh i would tell you paid off in three
years
beans and rice rice and beans and work
your way through it and i don't know why
you can't do that in this situation
um you know and uh
yeah you're you may have a roommate
situation you are
an inexpensive property that you're
living in but if you made seventy
thousand dollars a year and a hundred
thousand dollars worth of student loan
debt that's what you would do anyway
so that's not different the only thing
that's different is you are in a high
stress high pressure cooker situation as
a resident so
and 80 like you said 80 hours a week so
no opportunity to make any more
you are stuck with that income uh but
the payoff
and you do have this payoff at the end
but yeah i'm going to go ahead and clear
it
it's going to take you two and a half to
three years to clear it but i'm going to
go ahead and clear it because that's how
i'm going to treat it
is is if you're just made 70 grand and
you had 100 what would you do well you'd
pay it off
and i'm going to tell you something it's
going to sound counterintuitive i've
done some
research on med student mental health
and in fact i'm going to speak to med
school here in the fall
i would lean towards not
living what you would call a solitary
life where you work 80 hours and you go
by yourself into a home
and you can just you can shut everything
down i would actually
especially in your first couple years of
residency
want you leaning in and having some
friends i'd recommend have some
roommates man have some people you can
go home to
and that can be with you and be a human
with you
one of the biggest challenge that
medical residents have is this becomes
their planet their universe and it is
dealing with other people's pain and
trauma
all day long 24 7 365 and no sleeping
grab a
grab a granola bar on the way to the
next thing and the next thing
hey man there's something about being
tethered back to a group of people i
tell you to live light man
people that you're not treating yeah i'd
say to live light have a group of people
that you're
sharing life with that's not gonna sound
like i'm in residency i'm a doctor
i'd say have a house full of roommates
get this debt paid off and then you're
gonna look up three or four years later
you're gonna be living a lot lighter man
then you can make some different
decisions
yeah good good call alex is next in
phoenix hi alex welcome to the ramsay
show
i'm dave and john pleasure to speak with
both of you you too what's up
so my wife and three of our four kids
were recently in a
car accident which totaled our vehicle
oh no is there a way okay
all right yeah yes it was a pretty bad
accident but
thankfully everyone is just fine good
good
so working on replacing it and i'm
comparing a lot of vehicles
of the same make and model very similar
model year and trim level
the only real difference are the miles
and the price so is there a calculation
i can use to help decide which vehicle
has the best value
based on that vehicle's mileage and
price
uh so i assume you've got the money to
buy whatever you want
with some reason yes i mean within
within the range that you're talking
about you've got the cash either way
yes we do so the simple thing is just
how to put a valuation on a vehicle
yes okay uh i mean you can hit a little
bit more money
probably the uh the goal the gold
standard is
uh is uh uh
in terms of placing a value on a vehicle
would be kellybluebook.comkbb.com
edmonds car guide is pretty good as well
that's not a bad one
there's four or five sites you can go to
you can look at trader.com and just look
at other vehicles exactly like it that
are for sale
uh and a lot of these sites now overlap
and have apis where they talk to each
other and everything else
so it's fairly easy if you just spend an
hour or two surfing
to actually put a pretty good valuation
on the vehicle
in terms of what is uh the the best
end quotes value um
uh usually the older the vehicle with
the lower the miles
uh and so if you had a a 20 i don't know
i'll make it up
2015 with uh 15 000 miles
or you had a a 2018
with a hundred thousand miles the 2015
is going to be more bang for your buck
usually
because it's got more life left in it it
didn't lose much life during those three
years
the miles put more on it than that years
do in terms of the actual
uh use of the vehicle typically
i mean it can depend on the car
obviously but
the other thing you get into is the
technology advances so quickly in the
newer ones
that um it's just the creature comforts
and the newer ones are big time
different sometimes two years makes a
world of difference
uh in terms of trying the goodies just
just to decide if it's worth it spending
a few extra thousand to you know have
you know 10 20 000 miles left it sounds
like you're saying it's not value-wise
even though the vehicle might not last
as long i am still getting more value if
it has
a higher mileage in the lower price
yeah um i think that's very car specific
yeah
and it's you know you know if we're
talking about 200 000 miles we're
talking about 20 000 miles it's a lot
different
but uh um but i mean what kind of car
are you looking at
a honda odyssey oh an odyssey okay and
and what price range
uh um 13 to 19.
okay and what kind of miles of range are
we playing with here
so to give you a few examples we have a
hundred and forty four thousand miles
for thirteen five hundred and fifteen
thousand miles for
seventeen four seventy five thousand
miles
for nineteen one now
the only one that would get my attention
based on the miles would be the 17 the
uh the uh the 13 would sound like the
deal
with the 144 yeah that's one that
sounded like it sounded like the deal
because the the you know the good news
about honda i mean it's just
you don't have to be a rocket scientist
no that thing's got a two it's a 250 000
mile car
if you take care of it so it's it's got
it's got 100 000 miles left in it
um you know it's it's not worn out
if they've taken anywhere near care of
it i mean i don't know what condition
they're in that kind of thing but
um yeah i
you're not gonna mess up none of those
right there are going to ruin your life
would not overthink if a car's got 1000
miles more i wouldn't overthink it yeah
but 75s you know it's a lot different
you jumped way down all of a sudden
on that one and that's the only one that
kind of got my attention but the other
one for
13 was the first one that got my
attention interesting
none of those are dumb no you win with
all three yeah
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage
mark and ashley are here with t-shirts
that say weird people so they must have
paid off their house way to go
guys how much debt have you paid off uh
four and six thousand
seventy-five dollars that's house and
everything huh house and everything
i am looking at weird people i love it
and how long did this take you uh 53
months good for you that's perfect
and your range of income during that
time start about about 140
250 to 250. wow what do you all do for a
living
i'm a veterinarian and i stay home with
our kids
and take care of them and i breed dogs
on the side
and babysit and homeschool and
sell things and you got a place you got
a place to sell the dogs through this
vet you know huh
so what kind of dogs uh standard poodles
oh yeah
all right big boys huh yeah all right so
one of you
approached the other and said i have an
idea
let's get shirts
there you go it was the veterinarian has
the fun
ideas you're asking about their money
i just want to know who came up with
this idea that's it okay so 53 months
ago you decided to pay off your house
what caused that and how did you do it
um so we had just bought into the
practice
um and i was about like five to six
months after that
i was outside grilling one afternoon and
it just like we did the budget we were
kind of
doing davish at that point and at the
end of our month
it was just tight like everything felt
tight
and uh i was thinking about like how
much money we made like this is
ridiculous
they make way too much money to feel
this way um
and that was my yeah that was my it
moment
we had paid off our student loans before
that and
we grew up hearing about you dave and we
had applied some of it
um but i always felt we always felt
really good because we didn't ever
have big balances on our credit cards or
i didn't bounce checks at the bank
but we could not get any traction we
really were slow to pay off our loans
and for the amount of money that we made
at the time i just felt like it
should be more it should work better
so that's when we decided to submit to
the principles and get it done
okay so you investigate a little deeper
and figure out exactly what the details
were to do the baby steps and to do our
stuff
yep and did you go read a book or go
through financial peace or just listen
to show or what
we listen to the show a lot i actually
heard
a lot of financial piece growing up my
family didn't practice it but
my parents enjoyed listening to you um
i actually took a class through my
church as a teenager
too i like a young adult um i just
didn't
i felt like i was pretty smart i didn't
i didn't i have to
i have to do everything my way first
yeah i got it okay so you just kind of
went back and revisited
yeah all of that and said okay we're
going to really do the stinking plan
yep i think just hearing hearing
people's debt-free screams hearing you
every day
a lot of the stuff that you speak is
truth
and it really um it really got to our
hearts and
eventually you're like he is he has
helped lots of people
so we're going to get him i'm so proud
of you guys yeah
very very cool very cool so that's all
where do you guys live what city uh
green bay close to green bay oh okay
so what's this four hundred six thousand
dollar mortgage house that doesn't have
a house another mortgage on it worth
uh the house is worth uh 250 probably
now
250. so maybe about half of that's the
practice buy-in oh
okay half of it's the house and so you
own the practice 100 or your partners oh
eight partners yeah hey partners okay a
small animal large animal everything
large animal large animal the whole
thing's large animal yeah wow
okay and my dogs and your dogs and i
have to do this those are large animals
there
this is not a toy yeah that's a it's a
standard yeah wow very cool you guys
got this moment you're on your back
porch i just have a picture of you
in my head of you raising a spatula to
the sky saying no more
pretty much yep and you brave heart with
a spatula
and lightning strikes and then you come
in and you tell your like
walk us through that that conversation
yeah so he probably would have done this
a lot sooner i was the one who dragged
my feet for sure
um i just really like stuff yeah i like
to buy stuff and
uh looking back i just really struggle
with self-control
struggle with contentment
so yeah his his job was convincing me
to get on board and i love him i want
him
to be happy and to thrive and do well um
and so that's kind of what he does
you can thrive in that atmosphere i want
him to be happy in my lexus
yes that's correct yeah
so it took a little while for me to come
on board um so what's the first big
thing you're going to get to do now that
you don't have
any debt i bought her a new van or a
newer van
yeah that's perfect it was coming for a
while yeah
it was needed i can tell the funny story
was that i knew she had bought in
the year before we bought the van uh
we had set aside from the air and bonus
stuff to buy a van
and uh it was like a few days into that
like after we'd set it aside
she came to me and said um
i think i'd rather put this towards the
house wow
and i had done the math and i had mapped
out if we put this towards the house
and your bonus towards the house and we
pay on it like we've been paying off our
debt
then we can we can probably pay the
house off in a year and i think
it's only going to get harder because
we've got kids that are growing and
they've got plans and goals and wow
he grabbed that spatula and he waved it
that's right
we're in it so good man i love it well
congratulations what do you guys tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
i think um the why just having
a big y and the bigger the y the better
um i think the most important thing you
say
say every day that dave is um the only
way to true financial peace
is to walk daily with the prince of
jesus christ jesus
and that's a huge why of um
we're stewards i mean you talk about it
all the time we're stewards
and um that money's not ours
um it's we're responsible for taking
care of it and using it wisely
yeah and for me it was learning that
self-control
and contentment sometimes i reflect back
it felt like a really long time
especially when you look at the the time
that we were davish all the way to
paying off the house pretty much our
marriage we've been paying stuff off and
trying to live frugal and
trying to get good at that and sometimes
i look back and i think
it took that long for god to get through
my
to get through to me to change my heart
but um
i definitely would say for me that was
it
and honestly i'm a bit of a wheeler and
a dealer i love to
see the potential in things and i'm
really good at selling things and
doing that stuff but my superpower ended
up being
just to sit still and to save our money
and not spend it and to find ways to
grocery shop better that's a life change
right there
that's a family tree change right there
godliness with contentment is great gain
so you brought the kiddos with you what
are their names and ages
we've got reuben who's ten vienna who's
nine tori is seven
maddie's almost six and jen's almost
four okay and they have the t-shirts
you are looking at it the why
what are we looking at we're looking at
weird people
[Music]
it's not it it's an exclamation point i
love it
well we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you because that's the
journey you're obviously on what a great
looking family
and of course you uh also will give you
a copy of the total money makeover to
pay it forward and give to somebody
start their journey so
you are looking at weird people
exclamation point that's perfect you're
looking at a change family tree it's
incredible
that that's awesome very cool very very
well done
all right mark and ashley rubin vienna
victoria madison and geneva
count it down 406 000 paid off in 53
months making 140 to 250.
let's hear a debt-free screen ready
three
two one
[Applause]
[Music]
wow wow
man that's powerful that's incredible a
lot of transformation happening not only
in their family tree but in each of the
individuals that's
powerful stuff right there wow every
decision they make is going to toss in
everything
the practice it's all uh not a debt
in the world so powerful
whoa this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today ecclesiastes 7 12
the protection
of wisdom is like the protection of
money and the advantage of knowledge is
that wisdom
preserves the life of him who has it
albert einstein says we cannot solve our
problems with the same thinking we used
when we created them oh
amen on amen amen requires new thoughts
that's what we're here for usually
requires some new thoughts
yeah some of them are good new uh
actions kevin is with us kevin is in
fort walton beach hi kevin welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave hi john thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
uh so um the question that i have is
about life insurance so we
are debt-free except for a house we
are currently renting um and
the plan for the financial freedom as we
should be i guess kind of at a
financially free point and
i would guess about five years uh but my
question is
so how much how much and for how long
should we get life insurance assuming
we're going
to be able to self-insure in a fairly
short
time horizon okay
self-insure means that five years from
today you're going to have a paid for
house
your kids are grown and gone or you have
so much money
that your kids are taken care of if you
die
anyway how old are you so we uh we are
both my wife and i are 34.
and you're renting we are currently
renting
we do have two children okay and how
much money do you have
uh currently we have around five hundred
thousand
okay and what do you make a year
um so we are our income right now
is about 140.
we live on about a third of our income
so we're able to put a lot of into
investments
and then my um so due to a
job change probably within about a year
our income should be increasing
substantially
okay i um well i mean apparently you
understand
the or or my definition of self-insured
is
is there's enough money in in
investments
that your family will have enough income
coming off of those investments without
touching the principal
to take care of them easily
without your income being there your
income is replaced by income off of
investments without having to touch the
actual principle of the investments if
you're going to be there
in five years then you know you're there
are you guys healthy yes
okay because here's the thing i mean a
million dollars on a 34 year old just
doesn't cost
the cost of a pizza it's not much money
and so and i do yeah
you're not and i guess that's my
question is do we do that because i know
you
kind of typically recommend the 10 to
12. yeah
i'm just saying but well i mean if you
buy a million and a half on you
uh or whatever you know i mean it's just
not much money
we're not talking about some super
expensive policy if you go to
xanderinsurance.com
and you quote out a million and a half
two million whatever on a 34 year old
it's just not that much
it doesn't cost that much so um you know
if you buy that for a 10 year or a 15
year
uh i'd probably just buy a 15 year and
then when you reach the point that you
uh are self-insured by the definition i
just gave you
uh that your wife and children are you
know they got 100 000 a year to live on
so you've got
um you know million me and a half in
investments
that that they can draw off of uh once
you reach that point you would just
cancel the insurance if you want to
um you may find other uses for it but um
uh
in terms of just padding things and that
kind of stuff but um
it's yeah the difference in a 10 year
and a 15 year is not going to be
substantial enough at 34 years old to
screw with it i wouldn't worry about it
or even a five-year i mean it's just not
it's not going to blow you away that
it's it's not triple
you know it doesn't cost that much more
and um so
i would probably just go ahead and get a
15-year 12 times your income and then
if you reach self-insured before the 15
years is up cancel it
and i i look at those decisions in my
life dave on a
on a see-saw and of risk
right and so what's 500 bucks or six or
seven hundred dollars a year
versus my family being taken care of
if something happens it just doesn't
make any sense on the other side of it
right i have the advantage
and the distinct disadvantage of having
sat with 34 four-year-old widows
yeah yeah that had two million dollars
yeah or had nothing
correct as if i and it's it's versus 500
bucks
right you know for the cost of policy or
whatever it is you know
and it's um it's not just a game changer
that's such an
understatement right such an overused
cliche to say that
it's it's it's oxygen yeah it's
everything
it's not the money replaces somebody or
anything like that but
it's a way different conversation man
to be sitting in that living room with
somebody and they're going dave you know
and they're friends of ours you know and
dave you know he he we did this stuff
you said to do in the class man and we
got
you know i got a two million dollars
coming and i'm
scared i'm gonna mess that up yeah
that's a that's a different thing than
that i'm scared and then i'm scared i'm
how we're gonna eat next week i gotta go
to work on monday
yeah so it's just it's not that much
money yeah carson is with us in st
louis hey carson welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um so my wife and i uh for the last year
and a half
have been on baby steps four five and
six
uh the the two years prior to that um we
were on
steps one two and three and paid off uh
about eighty thousand dollars in debt
um my question is so we've got a little
one-year-old
boy and my wife well we're both kind of
contemplating together
she wants to quit her job and what does
she make you know i'm
what does she make she makes
probably will be about 135 this year
what do you make
i make about 150 160 so what do you lose
when she comes home
and your income goes in half
well so the way that we've been living
right now
essentially we're you know living off of
my income and saving everything from her
and and a little bit but
well a lot of it yeah yeah well i mean
you're saving 135 000 that you won't be
saving anymore
exactly yeah and that's okay
so you're not going to be quite as
wealthy but she's going to get to be
there with her baby
do it okay well and i'm all for that too
but i also know
what you know 135 and growing over the
next five or ten years if we put all of
that into an investment account
and you know what that can grow up to
you know and
you know i work what does she do what
does she do what does she do for a
living
she does uh digital advertising okay
i i would tell her just for the fun of
it for the for the intellectual
stimulation
to do some freelance absolutely just to
keep herself busy
because a one-year-old drives you
freaking bananas but the uh uh
and if she'll stay current in that world
she can step back in whenever she wants
or whenever you all want you have
absolutely no financial need to do that
and
i trade uh one-year-olds for money in
about 30 seconds
yep yeah and and i i totally agree with
you
um it's more just is it is it uh
you know what we could have in the
future is it a wise decision i
i you don't need it your side i think
you don't need it okay
yeah hey it's not a math problem carson
you can be you can be multi-millionaires
on 150
000. okay and by the way you're not
gonna make 150 000
in the future because you're going to be
making more and she's also going to have
some freelance income
and when the kids are eight and nine and
ten and she's sitting at home by herself
while they're at elementary school she's
gonna go back to work and do something
because this woman likes what she does
she just likes one-year-olds better yeah
way more than i'm worried about your
your income i'm worried about her
identity and so she's i'd recommend her
getting some
um professional women some stay-at-home
mom women in her circle
yeah and she she's got a good great
community too and and so
uh i think that makes me a lot more
comfortable with this decision just
hearing you guys talk it out
so i really appreciate that thank you
i'm so proud of you guys i'm proud that
you got up to baby step four where you
can do this with and it's a no-brainer
yeah y'all worked hard to get to this
exact moment this is this is living like
no one else so that later you can live
and give like no one else this is
exactly what you're doing
well done very proud of you john good
show thanks man
good show james and kelly in the booth
i'm dave ramsey your hosts will be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
[Music]
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
you